yes how you doing doctor almost fine sir
thank you
okay I was told that my sciatic nerve
that my right side of my hip and the
lower part of my back own down to my
knee it hurts like hell okay and they
told me that I needed me I'm a hip
operation and I want to know what should
I think
okay let's see here hold you sir huh
what is your age how old are you
Oh 70 okay and how much do you weigh
what's your body weight are 201 okay
any other issues have a pressure
diabetes blimp miss you
how about pressure okay okay Charmaine
you there I'm here okay here's a
gentleman Sydney because high blood
pressure he also has sciatic he has
problems with his right hip down his leg
and his knee and the doctors want to do
a hip surgery maybe even some back
surgery what would you do for this guy
what do you think is actually the cause
of his problem well for all his issues I
would get him on a gluten-free diet for
one thing and I would get him on two
healthy bone and joint packs and I'd get
him on the ultimate daily classic in the
niacin plus and the vitamin d3 and of
course he's got to avoid all bad stuff
okay exactly right
okay as a Shar says Sydney you need to
get two healthy bone and joint packs per
month that will allow you to have a full
dose everything twice a day except for
the gluco gel that'll allow you to have
15 a day five at breakfast five at lunch
five a dinner time they're designed to
support and promote mater's repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue here comes discs between the
vertebrae bone makes the bone the cell
and then a vitamin d3 it gets two
bottles of the vitamin d for using take
three of those twice a day that's going
to help you absorb the minerals more
efficiently from your intestines and
also help you deposit these murals in
your bones more efficiently then the
ultimate daily classic tablets will
support healthy blood pressure and
those blocked arteries give us a call
every couple of weeks